local cox crews from las vegas are  headed down to louisiana to help restore  network services destroyed by ida six  local techs along with their bucket  trucks and rvs are on the road right now  a total of 50 will provide relief to  employees who survived the hurricane our  local crews have done their local crews  have done this before helping out in the  wake of other natural disasters  if you'd like to help out you can you  can donate to the american red cross  disaster relief it'll go to survivors of  hurricane ida and other natural  disasters just visit redcross.org you  can also give them a phone call 1-800  red cross or send them a text message  you can text red cross to  90999 to make a 10 donation if you  didn't catch that it's already posted on  our website